collègues se sont actuellement 6500
soignants en pédiatrie qui ont signé une
lettre ouverte au président de la
République où il dénonce les mises en
danger quotidiennes des patients dans
des services saturés on cause l'épidémie
de bronchiolite et des services
hospitaliers très fragilisés qui peinent
à recruter et à garder du personnel
notamment par médical pourtant
l'épidémie de bronchiolite est
habituelle à l'automne et donc
prévisible monsieur le ministre cette
situation n'est malheureusement pas
nouvelle en 2019 déjà faute de place en
réanimation des enfants ont dû être
transférés hors de la région
Île-de-France mais aujourd'hui ce
problème se pose avec acuité sur
l'ensemble du territoire et des enfants
sont régulièrement transférés d'un
hôpital à l'autre parfois même à plus de
200 km comment en est-on arrivé là les
capacités d'accueil des services se
dégradent en raison de la fermeture de
lit et de manque de personnels soignants
on manque de médecins libéraux on
restreint l'accès aux urgences et on ne
fait plus appel au kinésithérapeute pour
les bronchiolites pourtant
d'après une étude la plateforme a qui
respire l'offre de soins en kiné
respiratoire permet de réduire de 13%
les consultations pédiatriques au CHU de
Bordeaux le week-end toujours le même
constat le gouvernement n'a rien
anticipé et gère la pénurie avait des
rustines le déclenchement de plan blanc
oblige à déprogrammer des interventions
chirurgicales pour une simple épidémie
bronchiolite sans qu'il y ait
véritablement de perspective
d'amélioration
vous avez annoncé le déblocage de 150
millions d'euros pour les services en
tension à l'hôpital notamment pédiatrie
mais Monsieur le Ministre est-ce que le
gouvernement envisage enfin de mettre en
oeuvre des mesures structurelles en
revalorisant significativement la
permanence des soins de nuit du week-end
des jours fériés en augmentant le nombre
de pédiatres en libéral et à l'hôpital
et en acceptant qui est kiné puis à
nouveau intervenir pour lutter contre
l'épidémie de bronchiolite comme c'était
le cas auparavant